on referme ce journal avec de la danse
et le battle be the one qui s'est
déroulé samedi 3 décembre à la halle
culturel de la mairie à trappes
plusieurs compétitions ont eu lieu toute
la journée le public a pu découvrir
notamment du breakdance du new style ou
encore du krump plusieurs asie blinois
participer à cette journée battle
reportage d'haussmann vendeurs d et
nicolas landry et figure sur une main
coupole danse au sol ou encore new style
voilà ce que les spectateurs ont pu
découvrir lors du battle be the one ces
petits 3 décembre à la halle culturel de
la mairie à trappes et pour gagner cette
compétition
les règles sont strictes donner du
plaisir au public et être rythme par
notre secrétaire du ressenti sur le son
donc ça dépend des sentiments que à le
danseur sur le sont donc on a des
critères dans le hip hop qui sont le
boom bas c'est à dire de respecter le
boom bap donc ça vient du coeur quoi
c'est un battement du coeur qui nous
permet justement de et danser de données
a ressenti au public pour jusqu'à
jusqu'au moment où l'usure le mans c'est
c'est l'instinct sur le moment et parmi
les danseurs il y avait des yvelinois
comme choupi et bambino de danseurs the
new style originaire de trappes
malgré de très bons passages de leur
part ils ont perdu dès le premier tour
donc au niveau de ce battle
ressenti va très bon ressenti ça c'est
grave bien passé grosse expérience de
danse et contre ice et bein c'est sa
force et pas n'importe qui c'est à dire
que quand on savait qu'on allait tomber
contre le prometteur on savait qu'il
fallait envoyer directement parce que ça
va être chaud entre les deux premiers
niveaux il était super vraiment vraiment
où on est tombé contre john niveau dans
le baptême il était haut mais s'étaient
tous les deux qu'il lors de cette
deuxième édition il y avait plus de 500
spectateurs et plus de 100 danseurs
venus de toute la france pour
s'affronter au point où on en est
franchement ce matin ça commençait à
vraiment être un gros battle honey
nouveau les nouveaux dans ce milieu là
dans la création de ce battle là c'est
notre deuxième événement mais ça prend
de l'ampleur et offert 9 heures en effet
de ramener des grosses têtes au fur et à
mesure mais ça va prendre
et pour cette deuxième édition les
vainqueurs sont salim pour le breakdance
sarcelles élite en hip hop et jamie pour
le club